tonight a major issue surrounding ccsd
and the return
to in-person learning and playing yeah
the board of trustees
listening to parents comments tonight
and the issues really just ran the gamut
arc omana is in the newsroom to sort it
out out for us orco
well denise and brian ccsc parents say
it's just been too much of this
distance learning and not enough of this
in-person activities those were just
some of the issues the board of trustees
tackled tonight
we must return to in-person learning in
the safest way possible
as soon as possible nevada governor
steve sisilak kicking off thursday's
ccsd board meeting on everyone's minds
reopening schools
some parents questioning if their
students will be safe what is the
trajectory to have
every school have improved ventilation
other parents protesting outside ccsd
headquarters demanding school sports
return
in addition to letting kids back in the
classroom we have states across the
country that have pulled this off safely
we all need to get on the same page for
the sake throw these kids a lifeline for
pete's sake
board members also touched on student
suicides in clark county a topic that's
gotten national attention
students who died by suicide over the
past year it was the majority that
was caused by firearm the board
discussing a resolution that would
require parents to sign an awareness
letter as part of student registration
acknowledging the safe storage of
firearms in the home it
is keeping students teachers and staff
safe from the threat of gun violence
but after a lengthy discussion trustees
decided to come back to it before june
first
the only thing that parents want us to
be focused on right now is whether or
not their kids are going to be educated
in the building
sometime this year
trustees also approved a memorandum
agreement to pay school psychologists
more
to increase recruitment and that's
especially important given the mental
health challenges
students have faced during the pandemic
reporting live tonight orgomana 8 news
now